c'est pas seulement l'enjeu de
l'élection présidentielle c'est lise et
c'est l'enjeu de la bien sûr que
l'élection présidentielle de savoir si
la gauche doit être au rendez vous ou si
elle va être complètement explosé danser
dans ses propositions
c'est aussi l'enjeu des législatives car
de mon point de vue on ne peut pas
arrêter la vie politique en disant
uniquement la question de la
présidentielle
moi j'ai toujours plaidé pour qu'il y
ait un programme commun entre guillemets
je sais que le mot fait vieillot mais
avec l'ensemble des forces de gauche qui
sont prêts à gouverner donc 2 jean luc
mélenchon à manuel valls ça la question
c'est ouais ouais le coeur où est la
décision
où est le centre de gravité si c'est la
logique de manuel valls
y aurait il ne peut pas être le centre
de gravité la preuve en est faite
puisque je ne vois pas pourquoi françois
hollande n'arrive pas à rassembler et
manuel valls qui est encore plus percuté
au moins psychologiquement pourrait le
faire donc la question centrale c'est le
ps ne peut survivre que s'il reste un
parti qui 1 se met au centre de gravité
de la gauche dans ses propositions dans
ces combats et deux s'il reste lié à une
volonté farouche et déterminé de
rassemblement de toutes les forces de
gauche et ne sombre pas dans le tropisme
du centre gauche qui aura peut-être son
temps à l'élection présidentielle ne
résistera pas longtemps aux duretés de
la période